bonjour à tous bienvenue dans la belle
équipe avant de commencer l'émission je
souhaitais revenir sur les propos de
Jean-Claude d'acier tenue ce mardi 27
décembre sur ce plateau je faisais alors
réagir mes invités autour d'un débat
intitulé violence des jeunes comment
dire stop
[Musique]
comprenez bien mais là j'ai pas là j'ai
pas la référence
mais les musulmans ils s'en foutent de
la République ils ne savent même pas ce
que le mot veut dire je souhaitais vous
dire que ces propos n'engagent que lui
et en aucun cas la chaîne ni la
rédaction de ces news la Grande Mosquée
de Paris a décidé de porter plainte
contre Michel Houellebecq elle reproche
à l'écrivain des propos tenus dans la
revue Front populaire cette phrase quand
des territoires entiers sont sous
contrôle islamique je pense que des
actes de résistance auront lieu Michel
Houellebecq évoque donc des attentats
des fusillades dans les mosquées dans
des cafés fréquentés par des musulmans
bref des Bataclan à l'envers et enfin le
souhait de la population française de
souche comme on dit ce n'est pas que les
musulmans s'assimilent mais qu'il
cessent de les voler et de les agresser
ou bien autre solution qu'il s'en aille
dans le nom évoque un cri de dégoût
je le disais on va commencer avec un
génie c'est un homme on n'est pas fait
du même bois que le commun des mortels
Pascal prout alors effectivement il y a
un côté génial dans Pascal pro c'est
vrai et on l'embrasse
vraiment ne soit pas stressé Nathalie on
est entre nous mais non mais non c'est
sympa
allez cette année l'animatrice préférée
des Français ils nous en sommes très
fiers à un grand bravo à Karine
Lemarchand première femme du classement
annuel réalisé par OpinionWay pour TV
Mag not notez qu'ils sont trois
animateurs de M6 ça figurer dans les
cinq premiers car il le marchand donc
mais aussi Stéphane Plaza et Julien
Courbet Nathalie était une fan des
Grandes Gueules je crois ouais t'écoute
dans ta voiture télé et donc tu as de la
chance parce que tes préférés c'est
Stéphane Mehdi et moi oui donc on est
tous là aujourd'hui
voilà la pression personne n'y connaît
rien ici en fait
des fans de la première heure qui sont
déjà allés deux fois à Saint-Barth sur
la tombe de leur idole
[Musique]
tout pour moi quoi on aura toujours dans
notre cœur notre Johnny c'est notre
bosse
le
rappeur américain a connu un succès
mondial grâce à son titre
gangstase Paradise
Tupac Shakur mais pas du tout
pas du tout en France mais je vous
sentais sûr de vous en plus
ce n'est pas Johnny Hallyday mais Joe
Davidson son sosie belge salut
c'est génial ça me touche énormément
parce que bon les tunnels il était
inaccessible et alors le voir comme ça
de près de pouvoir les toucher les
costumes c'est on a l'impression qu'il
est encore là quoi Tesla certes l'action
de la marque automobile électrique à
grimper depuis 5 ans mais sur l'année
2022 c'est un plongeon moins 72%, une
chute record la conjoncture n'a pas été
Tesla fermeture de sa méga usine en
Chine à cause du covid hausse des taux
d'intérêt aux États-Unis sur fond
d'inflation mais l'image de la marque a
été très abîmée par les comportements de
son fondateur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça s'appelle la charge émotionnelle bon
Elon Musk c'est aliéné 50 % des
acheteurs potentiels notamment ceux de
gauche démocrates sont coeur de
clientèle ambiguïté sur l'Ukraine
soutient à Donald Trump ou à des figures
de l'extrême droite à chaque fois
qu'ilon musk se lâche sur Twitter
l'action Tesla dégringole comme il y a
deux semaines quand il a annoncé bannir
de Twitter des journalistes qui lui
avait déplu le jour d'après l'action
Tesla chut encore de 4%. je vais au
théâtre je porte pas de Max etc etc etc
Benoît Hamon
ma femme m'avait dit que si Benoît Hamon
était élu et reprenait son nom de jeune
fille donc